i probably started dancing when i was
like three years old
it's tough the world has been taking all
of britney spears's mistakes and
holding it against her but could it be
possible she was the innocent one
all along you may remember her as the
iconic 2000s pop star who raised
millions of teen girls
we know you had her posters and albums
scattered across your room just like
us but behind her perfectly crimped hair
dates with timberlake and
international fame this star struggled
all throughout her childhood
while her family wants us to believe
they had an ordinary home life
it's no secret anymore that her troubled
pop star image
stems all the way back to her mickey
mouse club days with a hidden traumatic
childhood
and pressures that we could literally
never imagine having growing up
you're about to be asking who is the
real villain in brittany's story
what i do i just cope with it every day
let's throw back to the 1980s in macomb
mississippi
just like a lot of young girls britney
had dreams of making it big
but according to her she never exactly
fit in with pageant girls in her town
in fact she even admitted she thought of
herself as ugly growing up and had body
confidence issues at such a young age
i wished my hair was thicker i wished my
feet were prettier
unfortunately those thoughts are all too
relatable in today's world and our heart
breaks just thinking of little britney
struggling
but she never stopped working day after
day in the dance studio
and taking voice lessons and eventually
went on to prove her hometown wrong
not to be cliche but a small town girl
making it big
that's straight out of a movie yet her
life wasn't as perfect as
everyone thought in fact it was far from
that
brittany moved from mississippi to the
big apple where she first was rejected
from the mickey mouse club
and went on to compete in the 90s talent
show star search
where she lost so here we have a barely
10 year old girl facing not only
rejection in her hometown
but in the real world that couldn't have
been easy on such a small soul
in 1992 it seemed like she finally found
her place
and it was surrounded by some of the
industry's biggest celebs
her bff's ryan gosling justin timberlake
and christina aguilera were all a part
of the mickey mouse club alongside her
on screen she seemed like the happiest
12 year old with her upbeat personality
and magical voice
and even happily did a tour of the
studio years later
it's no wonder no one ever really
questioned what her home life was like
and it wasn't until years later that the
world found out that when britney left
set for the day
she went home to a scarily dysfunctional
home
in her 2000s tell-all novel britney's
mother lynn
opened up about the situation with her
ex-husband describing him as
an alcoholic who drags a would-be-happy
southern family
down the road to dysfunction britney's
uncle has also spun the tragic tale that
when her father became violent after
drinking
britney would spend the night at her
aunt's trailer down the road he even
once attempted to run away with brittany
but despite lin's attempts at divorce
and a protective order
the two stayed married for years to come
brittany's childhood is a reality for
tons of other american families
and not being able to talk about it in
the spotlight and deal with her emotions
at a young age
could have very likely caused some
lasting psychological problems
so could this be the reason for her
troubles down the road i mean even her
sister jamie spears
attempted to cover up the situation by
saying that her and britney's life
growing up was just like any other kid's
life
was she forced to say these things she
did after all
make her way into the spotlight on
nickelodeon's zoe 101
a short while later or was she just too
young to realize
when brittany moved on to the next stage
of her career nothing
changed well she became internationally
known and an idol to millions of teens
across the globe
but her problems during childhood only
came to the forefront
even more she was praised for her hard
work but sources claimed the only reason
she worked so hard
was to escape the life she was living
away from the spotlight
but then life as a star became just as
rough as life at home
britney's bodyguard once said that she
is the product of some very bad genetics
and it was only a matter of time before
britney's own mental health became the
forefront of the picture
let's put this in perspective britney
spent years of her life in a home with a
father who was an angry alcoholic
dealt with intense self-image issues and
then was thrust into the world of fame
where every bit of her life was seen by
the entire world
that's beyond rough that's almost
unimaginable
to top it all off those image issues
never stopped
and her acne outbreaks didn't make
anything better
with hits like baby one more time oops i
did it again
and i'm a slave for you piling up on the
hit charts
so did the pressure i mean britney
herself even wondered why she was even a
star i'm a shy person
and i'm particularly not really made for
this industry sometimes it can get kind
of lonely
you're guarded you know so why did she
continue to perform
is there something behind the scenes we
weren't aware of or was it still an
escape from
the reality she was living but slowly
her life away from the dysfunction at
home became her reality at work as well
she was being heavily controlled by her
agents stylists
producers and anyone who she should have
been able to trust
things got real dark she was only given
an
hour break each day for some down time
pretty sure that's illegal
and everything she did wore and said was
chosen for her
at this point was she even her own
person did we
ever really know who the real britney
was remember how the mickey mouse club
was kind of a safe house for her
well into her adulthood that also came
crashing down
until brittany basically had no one to
rely on her two-year iconic relationship
with justin timberlake
someone she trusted came to an end after
he accused her of cheating
i mean just look at the heartbreak in
her eyes during an interview about it
not to mention he publicly ridiculed her
with the song cry me a river
we've all been through messy breakups
but imagine the whole world watching as
they're happening
her childhood best friend christina
aguilera also turned her back on her
she called her a lost girl distant and
desperate for guidance
she was condemned for getting breast
implants at a young age and when she saw
the criticism
cried in the bathtub for hours did
brittany walk so the kardashians could
run
it sure seems like it but at what price
no matter how much she begged for a
break my anxiety
has just been crazy maybe i'm just
changing and getting older but i find
i need to have my down time just to
myself or i'll go crazy
she never got one until she finally
actually broke
she was just coming off of a drunk las
vegas marriage that lasted 55 hours
to then getting into her messy marriage
and divorce with kevin fetterline
not even britney's kids shawn and jaden
could save her from this one
can we blame her just take a look at
everything she's been through
all of her life not to mention growing
up and seeing her parents relationship
and lacking a proper father figure
definitely didn't help when it came to
her
own romance she even admits she married
for all the wrong reasons
and that she married because she liked
the idea of everything
she was still that little girl longing
for that normal life
she was reportedly abusing alcohol
constantly partying
and even her bodyguard admitted that she
was frequently on high risk illegal
substances
there might actually not be a meme more
popular than the one that includes
britney spears shaving her head
it was the peak energy of 2007 and let's
be honest
we'll probably be remembered for years
to come after that very public meltdown
britney spent months in and out of rehab
and even lost the joint custody she had
over her two boys
this caused her father to step back into
the picture yep
her father he reportedly has been sober
since the mid-2000s
enter the conservatorship and the
hashtag free britney movement that has
been literally
ruling the internet fans and now celebs
like snooki paris hilton and bella
thorne
are under the impression that she is
still being controlled like she was
earlier on in her career her father was
put in charge of all of her finances
every single penny since getting sick
her care manager has since
stepped in but this celeb literally has
no control of
any aspect of her life while her father
has tried to claim that these conspiracy
theorists don't know anything
and jamie spears has gone on to shut
down people who think her social media
posts are cries for help
we're just not so sure anymore in the
end how can we blame britney for all of
this
she never had a proper childhood she
never dealt with any of the issues she
was dealing with
both at home and in the entertainment
industry so how can anyone blame her for
the struggle she's gone through in her
adult life
we now know from experience that
everything is not what it seems
hello wizards of waverly place so the
hashtag free britney conspiracy in all
reality could be onto something
in other words keep petitioning you
britney stands she could use some
positive support
britney spears will go down in history
as one of the world's biggest
and brightest pop stars but at what cost
although it's reassuring that the celeb
seems to finally be on a more stable
path
the hashtag free britney movement is
worrisome
what do you think of britney's childhood
do you think it's the reason she
experienced such a troubled rise into
fame
spill all the tea with us in the comment
section below don't forget to give this
video a thumbs up and subscribe to the
things for more content just like this
catch you later
you